let's say you're on an interplanetary
mission to Mars millions of miles from
the nearest hospital and something in
your body goes awry houston we have a
problem say a routine body scan reveals
a potentially life-threatening blood
call what on earth or in space I guess
do you do if that happens here on earth
we rush someone to the hospital and we
can intervene if that happens on the
International Space Station our options
are incredibly limited a recent article
in the New England Journal of Medicine
describes an unprecedented medical event
in which an astronaut on the
International Space Station developed a
blood clot just two months into a
six-month mission so how did NASA handle
this unforeseen situation to find out we
spoke to one of the co-authors on the
article dr. James pattering he's a NASA
flight surgeon who's in charge of
astronauts health before during and
after spaceflight in this case patients
over 250 nautical miles overhead they're
traveling 17,500 miles an hour in orbit
around Earth there is no sure thing in
spaceflight space plays hard and so even
the perfect plan if it relies on things
that have a chance of failure may not be
something you can execute dr. Petrini
walked me through exactly what happened
during this uncertain time on the space
station
NASA is keeping the identity of the
astronauts secret for privacy reasons so
none of the footage you see will depict
any of the actual events walk us through
first of all how the blood cup was
discovered it seemed like it was kind of
by accident really
this particular astronaut was
participating in a study called fluid
shifts um what comes as a part of that
study is a number of in-flight
ultrasounds and upon analyzing him here
on the ground team noted that there
didn't appear to be any flow any blood
flow and one of the large veins in the
neck the internal jugular pain so when
this was found or of course you know
very concerned not only because this was
the first time we'd seen this in space
but because when these things are found
on the ground they can be you know
potentially life-threatening so this
came as a surprise both to the astronaut
and to you folks on the ground because
the astronaut wasn't really showing
symptoms that might indicate a blood
clot there is no
risk factors for this individual
whatsoever we do risk stratification on
individuals for whether they're an
increased risk of forming clots or not
this individual was not terrestrially
were most concerned about clots forming
generally in the legs with the
concerning that pieces of them could
break off and cause what we call a
pulmonary embolism they go to the lungs
which should be very dangerous and could
threaten your life in space things work
very differently and one of the concerns
is we don't know what the natural
history of this would be in microgravity
when we found it we felt it had not been
there for very long you can tell this by
how it looks on the ultrasound when a
clot is relatively new it appears soft
and what we call friable so it's more
likely to look like it can break pieces
off and go places I mentioned the risk
of pulmonary embolism is of course the
other risk that we were concerned of is
that it would extend upwards towards the
brain these are things were very
concerned about and we really were faced
with two options it was either an early
return of the astronaut and so cutting
the mission short or remain in place on
station and treat and try to organize
and stabilize this blood clot so that
when the time did come to come home that
it would not pose as much of a risk
why not just say okay we're going to
bring you home immediately and treat you
on earth coming back to Earth is a very
violent activity
there's the g-forces of reentry that
dynamics being shaken around like you're
inside of a washing machine the chute
coming out on any Castle followed by the
car crash of the landing these are all
considerations that with a soft fresh
cloth we were very concerned that the
decision to simply come home would take
a patient who's asymptomatic and doing
fine and place them at risk of
dislodging a piece of this and going to
the lung / elsewhere so once the
decision to treat was made by the
clinical care team things tend to move
very quickly
fortunately we actually had a supply of
one type of anticoagulant an ox apparent
injectables we knew that we only had on
the order of around 40 days a maximum of
this injectable supply
so that was not going to get us
certainly to the end of the mission we
were starting to manifest a resupply
vehicle with an oral medication I'll
call the PICC Seban that takes up much
less mass in space destined for the
International Space Station
a perfect resupply something could go
wrong we lose resupply vehicle all the
time and so having your backup plan and
your back-up plan to your backup plan
certainly when the health of look
remember lying on it weighs very heavily
on on the patient your team yes you have
your diagnosis but you are somewhat
removed from the patient in this
unprecedented situation how do you go
about treating somebody who's on the
space station while you're still on
earth in this case the astronaut is both
tasked with being the patient and also
Tashman being the hands of the treatment
team we take gravity for granted and a
lot of ways in one of the ways is
anytime you looked at a bottle with some
fluid in it here you see a nice meniscus
all the food goes to the bottom but
really surface tension predominates in
microgravity and so what you'll see is
the fluid kind of filling the interior
but leaving a cavity in the center if
you want to get the fluid out there's
different techniques that astronauts
have developed a consuming
centrifugation where you literally
you'll see astronauts spin to try to use
centrifugal force to get the fluid to
collect on one part of the file you can
also kind of try to go around the inside
of the vial with with the bevel of your
needle and try to suck it up as you go
but it's certainly a lot more
complicated I'm also curious how you go
about choosing drugs to send to the
International Space Station we've got
nine medical kits on the space station
they have a different kind of spectrum
of medications and medical supplies in
each going all the way back to Apollo
they didn't know what they needed and so
what they relied on was crew feedback
and go back to the Apollo mission
reports and what you see is it after
every single mission that conscious of a
medical kit changed and so if we
everyone agrees for example that you
need save something for nausea well
there's a pretty broad spectrum of
medications that can be used for that
but if it's something injectable then
you think of all the mass and volume
that comes along with the needles and
the syringes and the fact that they
can't be reused and how do you sterilize
things if you do knee degrees and all
these things go into consideration of
well maybe we'll have an injectable but
how much of that are you going to fly
versus how much of the oral medication
which can be back to very very tightly
the astronaut continued to take the
blood thinner throughout the mission
NASA says that the astronauts normal
duties were not affected by the
additional medical care but the
strangest and maybe most consequential
part of the event happened after the
astronaut came home the last time we
assessed it was the day prior to return
and we saw that there was still absent
flow in microgravity we assessed it
immediately upon bringing the astronaut
back to earth and saw that completely
normal flow had been restored by ten
days after return there was no evidence
of the cloud you could not find any
residual whatsoever which really nails
home that the microgravity environment
that we think is playing a significant
role here upon further investigation in
the study that originally found the
blood clot a new discovery emerged a
former astronaut who had participated in
the study also showed signs of a
possible blood clot
now there's 11 individuals as part of
the study 2 out of 11 if real is
certainly concerning to us and there's
flow of normality seen and more than
that if this is truly you know occurring
and around 20% of our astronauts it
raises a number of questions number one
has this really been happening for 50
years and we're just finding it now it's
absolutely possible
are there other risk factors that
predispose some people to developing
these clots and and we just don't really
understand the interaction between
microgravity and those risk factors
that's absolutely possible as well I
think the biggest question now is if
this has been occurring and this is
something that we're just going to
routinely see in human spaceflight what
does that mean for doing these longer
exploration class missions it's one
thing one as I said if something goes
wrong we can get people home in a number
of hours from the International Space
Station it's just not on the cards
you're days away for anywhere even the
moon and you know certainly much longer
if we go to Mars or anywhere else
and this isn't the only medical issue
that might complicate prolonged
spaceflight there's something called
spaceflight associated neural ocular
syndrome we call it stands for short
this is also a relatively recent time
because within the last decade it's a
remodeling of the back of the eye and of
the optic nerve itself how do we prevent
it how do we treat it these are things
we're still learning about and that's
still relatively new that's within the
last decade and now we see that there's
changes in blood flow I think the
question of how bad is microgravity
learning it does more similar things
that human body at first it was you know
loss of bone density okay we've got that
under control okay now it's loss of
muscle mass well we've got under that
that under control as well now it's this
remodeling of the eye and the optic
nerve we're getting smart on that and
we'll solve that eventually I'm sure and
now there's you know propensity to form
clots perhaps and these flow
abnormalities in the venous system and
now every US astronaut who flies
periodically in flight we are looking at
these vessels and other large vessels
with ultrasound to understand those flow
patterns better and to find if there's
any other clots that develop in any
other crew person we evolved to need 1g
of gravity and I think we need one
geographic and so the the question of is
one six G on the moon enough if we're
going to live there for a prolonged
period of time is that enough to make
these things go away that's an open one
I would say probably not I think it will
address in part of this spectrum but not
the full thing I think 2001 with the big
rotating space stations and is there a
solution and engineering solution to
provide some level of gravity to our
astronauts to mitigate these types of
physiological effects and I think
eventually we're going to need something
like
as we venture farther and stay longer in
space it's likely we'll discover even
more limits to our biology this mission
is too important for me to allow you to
jeopardize it this incident is a
reminder that NASA must be ready for
anything because we aren't about to let
the robots have all the fun in space